hello there guys in this video we're
going to be going over a league of toby
maguire and spider-man no way home so
without further ado let's play the
league's voice line on my world our tv
side you both have web shooters so i
think this voice line is actually fake
and i'm going to debunk this for you
guys in this video so basically this is
website where you can do like ai voice
generation um it says he deep fake text
to speech so basically you can use um
actors or characters from movies like
toby maguire spiderman you just type
whatever text you want and click speak
and then it'll generate the line for you
my world octavius died you both have web
shooters so as you can see it actually
sounds pretty damn good but you're
probably wondering it sounds a bit
robotic where the league's version
doesn't have a robotic sound and
actually sounds like you know it could
be from a movie and let me get into that
so basically first off the voice line i
think has been edited to sound more
clearer using an editing software
perhaps adobe edition or audacity and
they've also added some background music
in the clip which i would say would help
mask out
the issues with the voice or make it
sound more legit so to prove this to you
guys i've downloaded the leaked voice
line and voice lines from the text to
speech website and i have made some
adjustments to to the ai voice i've
added a low pass filter and added some
bass to it and and basically this will
just get rid of the robotic sound and
part of the voice let me just play it
for you so you know what i mean on my
world octavius died you both have web
shooters now let's play the voice lines
both together
[Music]
now there you have it guys it basically
lines up pretty much perfect to the
leaked voice line both of the voice
clips are set exactly the same they have
the same emotion they're set at the same
speeds and you know all that stuff it
just lines up perfectly the only
difference is how the audio was edited
but the way it's spoken is the same so
guys let me know in the comment section
below if you think this voice line is
fake real let me know your thoughts in
the comment section below and also if
you want to see more videos like this
one do let me know and also like and
subscribe to show your support thanks
for watching guys